a nice on va retrouver pierre le lait un
habitant il est étudiant relève bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
quelle est l'atmosphère ce soir autour
de vous amener ce particulièrement les
gens j'ai l'impression qu'il ya vraiment
une tête de ras-le-bol et que les gens
ne sont plus comment dire horrifiée et
choquée comme il ya quelques années
c'est à dire que là avec ce qui s'est
passé il ya dix jours une dizaine de
jours avec le samu elle pâtit les gens
ils sont habitués au fait est ce qui est
effrayant c'est de se dire que c'est
devenu une sorte de après presque une
routine en france quoi voilà des fois
c'est il ya une attaque
moi je me suis arrêté j'ai tant en vélo
dans la rue principale et demande aux
gens qui se passe au niveau de l'automne
attentat d'une manière que c'est devenu
presque normal s'il ya plus de
sentiments de peur vous ne sentez bâle
2-2 de la peur ce soir à nice ah si si
la peur toujours mais c'est surtout j'ai
senti une espèce de de fatalité chez les
gens c'est à dire que ça peut tomber sur
n'importe qui séjournent en ont peut
être pas a pris à partie dans la rue et
que soit notre origine à couleur de peau
religion ou où nos opinions politiques
c'est vraiment très aléatoire et
impartiale et c'est à dire que ça peut
tomber sur n'importe qui c'est vraiment
c'est tombé sur moi
thaler voilà ça peut tomber sur
n'importe qui et les gens sont voilà
fataliste bon il ya eu toujours notée
l'action voilà ça apparaisse et mâcha
des gens qui disent ouais si les
musulmans ces machins bon il y aura
toujours des réactions infos comme ça
mais globalement les gens aient peur
mais il ya surtout une espèce de
fatalité que voilà maintenant ils sont
habitués les gens et c'est ça qui fait
peur au fait on le disait votre ville
est particulièrement bien équipé en
termes de sécurité notamment avec des
caméras est ce que vous attendez
davantage moi personnellement je suis à
nice depuis pas longtemps mais j'ai vite
remarqué qu'il ya un dispositif de
sécurité forts surtout depuis 2016 je
pense mais je vois que
je sens globalement peu d'insécurité
dans le centre de nice et je pense que
ses pairs en mettant plus de caméras que
ça va changer les choses parce que je
pense le que quelqu'un s'il veut tuer il
tuera qui sera prêt à mourir pour
prendre les armes comme ça faut être
déterminé et ne pas avoir peur pour
couper une tête comme ça dans la rue
faut quelqu'un qui veut tuer il tuera
donc je pense que c'est pas en
renforçant la sécurité
même les gens ils se sentiront un peu
plus
ambroise sur la beauté on non pas de
content et je pense que nancy est
quelque chose d'assez haut niveau je
pense au niveau de la part de l'état des
services de renseignement des de ceux
qui arrivant en france et bien sûr il
s'agit pas de dire que voilà c'est
confirmé les fronts selanne en faute une
cohabitation que les communautés mais
faut que les bains les instituteurs
reçoivent opérer plus vite quoi
exactement vous êtes étudiant
mais comment est ce que vous vous parler
de ce sujet là comment est ce que vous
avez vécu cette journée avec avec vos
amis étudiants également alors je n'ai
pas vécu mes amis aujourd'hui mais j'en
ai parlé dans l'après-midi avec eux et
sachant que je suis dans un cursus
international il ya des étrangers
notamment des gens dehors de l'est est
vraiment qui ils sont vraiment très
choquée comme à ce que veut la fin pour
eux ils ont une autre image de la france
et sur le terrain voilà ils sont là il
dit de france ça peut arriver à tout le
monde tout le monde n'importe quel cool
de la société un avocat mais pas
travailleur municipal ça peut arriver à
n'importe qui ils me disent vraiment
j'ai peur est en france je ne me sens
pas en sécurité
les gens de dents de lait d'ukraine
notamment qui me dit je me sens pas en
sécurité en france donc se poser des
questions quand même merci beaucoup
pierre le lait d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en direct sur esther t france
vous êtes étudiant